So, first off, we see our cookie
consent, right? So, we can see here we
use cookies to improve your experience,
accept or reject. Then we have the
ability to chat with the website. If you
didn't know, I've been doing a public
build of this website. We've built it
using RankSite AI, which allows you to
generate SEO and geo-optimized websites
with the help of AI in minutes rather
than hours. And these sites actually
index and rank and bring you in traffic.
Now, it's been a couple of weeks, and if
we go ahead and take a look at our
Google Search Console, we can see here
that this website is already getting
clicks and impressions. And again, as I
showed you here, this was nothing less
than a month ago. So, this website is
less than a month old, and it's already
getting clicks and getting impressions
as well. And as you can see here, we're
also ranking for the queries
that are relevant to this specific
website, and our pages are being
indexed,
and we're getting clicks from different
countries. If you go ahead and take a
look at our analytics, again, we can see
here that this again, this website gets
clicks, gets views, and it's starting to
rank, and it was a brand new website. We
can see here last week, it got over 80
active visitors, which is up 300%.
So, let's go through the build of the
site, and I'll show you some new
features that you can do with RankSite.
So, one of the biggest features we've
added is now you can integrate free apps
onto your website. So, things such as a
cookie consent banner, so self-hosted,
accessible consent banner, and it blocks
non-essential scripts until a visitor
agrees. So, you can turn it on and turn
it off. You also have the ability to add
on a site chatbot. So, this site chatbot
is going to be trained on your website
from the get-go. You have to do no
training on your end. You could give it
more information, but this
um AI will be trained on your website
based upon the inputs and the
information that we've already given the
website and then
users will be able to um ask different
questions. You can also add custom Q&A
answers if there's a specific question
and answer you want to add, you can add
that on. So, once we toggle on cookie
consent and our site chatbot, these will
be live on our website. We also have
some other widgets here that you can add
on, review widgets, privacy-friendly
analytics, and we'll be adding in some
other widgets and apps. So, we're going
to go ahead and save app
and then we're going to go over to our
site. We're going to open up our site on
a new incognito window so we can see
these new changes. So, first off, we see
our cookie consent, right? So, we can
see here we use cookies to improve your
experience, accept or reject. So, let's
say the user accepts it, great. So, you
can add that on with just a click of a
button. No need to get any third-party
tool. Then, we have the ability to chat
with the website. So, if I click on the
right-hand side here
this will open up my chat. So, now I can
ask the AI things
based upon this specific website. So,
for example, what services do you offer?
And it will tell me that. And if I go to
read more, it'll actually take me over
to that page. Very, very cool. So,
again, I can ask it another question
like what areas do we serve? And it's
going to tell me what areas it serves. I
can go to read more. And again, it's
going to take me over to that page. I
can also ask it how do I get a quote?
It's going to tell me and it's going to
take me over to the contact us page.
Right? So, very, very cool because not
only is it a chatbot, but it's kind of
like a site navigator. It helps
um guide the user throughout your
website and they can easily ask for
information. So, like what is your
prices or what are your prices, right?
To get your quote. And it also does not
use any AI call. So, this isn't cost you
any cost on your back end because this
is all retrieving the information that's
already on the site. So, there's no
actual AI call involved. So, you
wouldn't have to worry about racking up
costs for everyone for every time
someone ask a question using this
chatbot. So, it's very very easy to set
up. You literally have to do nothing
because in our end we take care of
making sure it's trained on the
information that you've given it. So, we
will continue to build out the apps and
add more apps into Rank Site. We're also
working on creating new templates. So,
right now our best template is for local
services, but we're going to create We
also have a general template as well
already, but we'll also create templates
for affiliates and other types of
websites. So, these websites are
beautiful. As you can see, they load
extremely fast. If I go over to my
PageSpeed Insights here, this is from
one of our sites. The inside that we
just built. As you can see, 90
performance, 91 performance, 100 best
practices, 100 SEO, and it loads
extremely fast and it is
mobile optimized as well. So, you can
use Rank Site to build websites for
yourselves or for
clients or to, you know, get leads in
the local area. The use case is really
endless when it comes to building sites
with Rank Site. So, if you guys wanted
to take advantage of the early bird
discount, we do have a $70 discount off
of all lifetime deals in description
below today's video. Try it out. You can
build a site for completely free.
And if you like it, then you can go
ahead and upgrade while we do have the
lifetime deals available because the
lifetime deals will not be available
forever with Rank Site because this is
going to be a monthly recurring cost for
a tool. So, hope that you guys enjoyed
today's video. I'll see you in the next
one. Take care.